good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight a significant day in the
recent history of the country we're
going to have an hour of details for you
but before we jump into them a little
bit of context here's how the story
started
just so we all remember
seventeen-year-old kyle rittenhouse
wound up on the street in kenosha in the
first place with a gun for one reason
he was there because in the summer of
2020 the leadership of the democratic
party endorsed mob violence for
political ends that's why there were
riots in kenosha that night because
people like kamala harris supported
those riots
more than a year later as rittenhouse
stood trial for murder those very same
people implied there would be more
violence if he was acquitted so imagine
being a juror on that case imagine the
pressure and the fear
it would take enormous moral courage for
any juror to ignore the threats and
follow the evidence to its logical
conclusion
so much courage that at times we doubted
it was even possible in a country as
politicized as ours now is
but as we learn today it is still
possible thank god
this afternoon the jury acquitted kyle
rittenhouse on all charges the jury
affirmed what was obvious from the very
beginning he acted in self-defense
it was a wonderful moment
anyone who believes in impartial justice
was vindicated here's what that moment
looked like
that's the first count of the
information joseph rosenbaum read the
jury define the defendant kyle h
rittenhouse not guilty
as to the second count of the
information richard mcginnis we the jury
find the defendant kyle h riddenhaus not
guilty as to the third count of the
information unknown mail we the jury
find the defendant kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
as to the fourth count of the
information anthony huber we the jury
find the defendant kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
as to the fifth count of the information
gage gross courts we the jury find the
defendant kyle adrian kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
remarkable
months of relentless lying from the
media about this case in the end had no
effect whatsoever on the jury
propaganda doesn't always win today it
was soundly defeated thank god
our documentary team was there in
kenosha when it happened they've been
there for days putting together an
installment of our tucker carlson
original series on this case and they
captured kyle rittenhouse's first
moments outside the court today after
being acquitted
it's the stuff that keeps you up at
night like once you finally do get to
sleep
your dreams are about what happened and
you're waking up in a in a dark cold
sweat yeah
you had dreams about what happened every
single night
[Music]
it's it's quite scary actually because
the dreams feel so real
and they're not the same at all they're
all different they're the different
scenarios that run through your head
during the day like what could have
happened like
i'm alive but what could have happened
like what if i wasn't alive or what if i
did
let mr roosevelt steal my gun it's those
type of dreams
it's bad but almost every outcome is
either
me getting seriously injured or hurt or
dead
those are just the dreams i have on a
daily basis
the defendant will rise to face the jury
and hearken to its verdicts
state of wisconsin versus kyle written
house as to the first count of the
information joseph rosenbaum read the
jury define the defendant kyle h
rittenhouse not guilty
as to the second count of the
information richard mcinnis we the jury
find the defendant kyle patrick house
not guilty
how do you feel man
the jury reached the correct verdict
self-defense is not illegal
and i believe they came to the correct
verdict and i'm glad that everything
went well and it's been a rough journey
but we made it through it
we made it through the hard part
if you watch that clip you're reminded
that maybe the one person in america who
hasn't yet weighed in on the kyle
rittenhouse trial
is kyle rittenhouse himself so for
months cnn and msnbc and kamala harris
have been allowed to define him that
ends monday we're sitting down for a
long interview with kyle right now so
you can see it on this show monday night
we hope you will
so technically as a legal matter this
case is over kyle rittenhouse has been
proclaimed innocent in a court of law
he's free to resume his life
but for the authoritarians among us this
is a disaster they can't let it go why
because they understand the written
house case is a referendum on the most
basic right of all the ancient rite of
self-defense if kyle rittenhouse can
save his own life from the mob
then you can too
and that drives them insane
so insane that the chairman of the house
judiciary committee today jerry nadler
of new york implied that kyle
rittenhouse may face federal charges
today's verdict nadler wrote justifies
federal review by the doj
so will joe biden's justice department
indict kyle rittenhouse now that he's
been acquitted by a jury in wisconsin is
hard to believe you'd have to be
deranged even to consider something like
that what would be the effect on the
country
but you never know with these people at
the very least this case will be used to
justify taking your guns away bet on it
but if this does go to the feds if kyle
rittenhouse is prosecuted by the doj the
case will likely be handled by kristin
clark she's the black nationalist who
runs the so-called civil rights division
of the justice department the division
that does not protect your civil rights
in fact it's trying to take them away
last year clark weighed in on the
written house case and immediately not
surprisingly zeroed in on written
house's color like his race was some
kind of crime she described him as a
quote armed white man
murdering innocent protesters at quote
point-blank range
what does his race have to do with
anything
well it doesn't have anything to do with
anything of course but it's been a
fixation of the democratic party from
the first moments they've tried to
racialize this case and by the way
kristen clarke is far from the only
member of the party to try and do that
just hours after the jury's verdict the
chairman of the democratic congressional
campaign committee sean patrick maloney
a congressman released this statement
quote it is disgusting and disturbing
that someone was able to carry a loaded
assault rifle into a protest against the
unjust killing of jacob blake an unarmed
black man
end quote
savor that for a minute that's from the
head of the democratic party's
congressional campaign arm
everything about it is wrong not just a
lie but factually i'm sure jacob blake
was not killed
he was also not unarmed
he was carrying a knife you know because
he said he was carrying a knife
he was allegedly trying to kidnap a
child that's why the police showed up
when he grabbed a knife they shot him
again that's not in dispute and he's
still alive
but it doesn't matter because these
people facts don't matter clearly
sean patrick loney has no interest in
what actually happened
kamala harris said that she was proud of
jacob blake last year the democratic
party is sticking with that too
they are trying
and they have from the very beginning to
make this case into a racial divide to
further divide the country kamal harris
today
said that the outcome of this case the
jury's verdict was proof
that our judicial system is not quote
equitable
whatever that means
it needs to be changed the attorney
general of the state of new york said it
needs to be completely torn down and
rebuilt our justice system that we've
had for 250 years it's the best thing in
our country the idea that you are tried
on the basis of the facts not on the
basis of what you look like but they'd
like to change that
abc news by the way just reported the
same thing
they told us abc news a news corporation
has told us that in fact jacob blake was
killed in kenosha watch this
well it's very significant first for the
community of kenosha this city was
traumatized
by the police killing of a black man
jacob blake
the police killing of a black man who is
in fact still alive
so what are they doing when they tell
lies like this lies that you can check
very easily or if you have a memory that
extends into last year you recall very
well
well they're inciting people of course
they're trying to whip people into a
frenzy on the basis of claims that are
totally provably untrue
what kind of a frenzy well consider this
this is from a senior advisor at the d
triple c the democratic campaign arm his
name is daiwan tatro he just issued an
explicit call for riots no justice no
peace he wrote in the wake of the
verdict who is daiwan tatro well he
according to news reports spent a decade
in prison after he shot two people now
he works for the democratic party just
in case you're interested in whose side
they're on
but you knew that
meanwhile a spokesperson for congressman
val demings the other democrat offered
this assessment the core of the
far-right movement is that they should
be able to kill you if they want to
that's the official line of the
democratic party tonight
keep in mind
and if you watch the trial you know this
kyle rittenhouse was walking down the
street when he was charged
by a convicted child rapist and then
charged by a number of other people
he sought no conflict there was never
any evidence that he was the aggressor
in any case
he was aggressed against
so joe biden also weighed in on this and
he gave two versions
of his views on it
first he said we're going to respect the
jury's verdict and then of course when
his advisors took over and wrote a new
press statement
he told us how upset he was by the
verdict and that's what aired on msnbc
all day
the next time there's a uh a protest of
some sort and it may get politicized
that
gun gun owners with a certain ideology
may feel incentivized now may feel even
emboldened what some may take from this
verdict is that vigilante justice
prevail knowing the history of vigilante
justice in this country all the way back
to times of enslavement
when people
would be deputized to go out and track
down enslaved persons who ran away
to lynching mobs
and this is 2021 it is to tell the
current and future kyle written houses
of the world that they can engage in
white vigilantism and be let off for it
be defended and protected for uh
perpetuating white supremacy
white vigilantes and white supremacy
white white white white white that was
all over media all day long explicit
racial attacks
what does that have to do with this case
and in what kind of country is that
allowed when the most powerful people in
the country level explicit racial
attacks against one of their countrymen
most of us didn't grow up in a country
where people talk like this it's very
honest that they're talking like this
now
just as a reminder in case you're tuning
in for the first time in a year everyone
involved in this case is the same color
the people of the council on american
islamic relations offered this take
which was very common today on the left
quote it is difficult to imagine a black
or muslim defendant engaged in the same
conduct being found not guilty
really
are you here for the oj trial it's
ridiculous
msnbc the network that was banned from
the courthouse for following jurors
around broadcast this racial screen
today from a relative of jacob blake's
now you tell us why he got a free ride
his barrel money was raised by the proud
boy the ku klux klan
uh the nazis the skinheads
are they plugged up in this courtroom
do we know the history of this judge i
already has been racist as hell that
means these people in kenosha for many
years
it's really really dark
the rest of us should not allow them to
get away with racializing this allow
them to get away with attacking people
on the basis of their skin color that is
always wrong we would never engage in
that never have and no one should do
that because it divides the country and
it's immoral flat out
but somehow through the crazy logic that
governs their positions and their deeds
they're wind up defending child rapists
and domestic abusers elevating them to
some sort of hero status the former
mayor of new york bill de blasio wrote
this today quote
anthony huber and joseph rosenbaum are
victims they should be alive today maybe
we'll get a statue a very small statue
to joseph rosenbaum in new york someday
meanwhile the aclu which you'd think
would be in favor of self-defense that's
the most basic of all civil liberties
suggesting that crossing state lines is
somehow a crime stay in your own state
here's what they said quote despite kyle
rittenhouse's conscious decision to
travel across state lines and injure one
person take the lives of two people
protesting the shooting of jacob blake
by police he was not held responsible
for his actions
this is insanity and by the way the
continuous references to crossing state
lines are not insignificant legally
they're meaningless you have a right to
cross state lines if you're an american
because it's your country you in fact go
to all 50 states and you're not breaking
a crime so why are they bringing that
phrase into every analysis of the case
crossing state lines
because they want to use this to change
gun laws that's why you watch
so if you want to know what the worst
people in the world are saying obviously
you're going to tune into jeb bush's
former flack on msnbc
she told us today that anyone who
crosses state lines is a domestic
terrorist
the kyle rittenhouse acquittal today not
guilty on all counts did not happen in a
cultural vacuum there's some alarming
context to this moment worth considering
and talking about just last week the
department of homeland security released
its latest bulletin warning americans
again of the ongoing threat posed by
domestic violent extremists we should
also point out conservative media for
many many months has been priming its
audience for this moment
framing written house as a hero
so why are we inflicting tape like that
on you on a day when all of us should be
celebrating we'll tell you why
because none of that made any difference
to the jury
and if you're totally absorbed in
american media you get the impression
that american media are in charge of our
country
and it turns out they're not
most people don't watch that crap they
don't care what people like that say
they don't care at all
there are a lot of rational decent
thoughtful people on all sides of all
races in this country who are still
willing to think clearly about what is
right what is wrong what is factual what
is false what is just
and what is not
and today they did
so that's the real lesson here in the
face of all of that propaganda a group
of jurors in kenosha wisconsin
were brave enough to reach the right and
obvious conclusion anyway amen
yay for america hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else